British diplomats may be out but
thousands of British Nationals remain
they've been told to stay put hold up
and Scattered across the capital
Khartoum conditions are horrendous a
wider evacuation hugely complex and
there's no clear Escape Plan
in London Sarah Scrolls through
desperate family WhatsApp messages she's
been sent a video of a hospital in
Khartoum after 10 Savage days of
fighting the dead bodies are too graphic
to show
Sarah asked us not to show her face she
and her brother Ali have been studying
at the hospital he and other family
members are still there I mean like
priorities went to be safe not only him
like everyone into that
it's a deeply worrying time Zara says
her brother who holds a British and a
Dutch passport needs help
my brother he was born and raised here
he spent 18 years of his life and the
last time we went back to Sudan prior to
this was six years ago so he doesn't
already know the streets I couldn't like
imagine what he's going through he
doesn't really have anyone this is a
total and absolute nightmare of a crisis
in the Commons Africa Minister Andrew
Mitchell said British diplomats were in
extreme danger but hit back at
comparisons to the chaotic evacuation of
British Nationals and others from
Afghanistan in 2021
the position in Sudan is completely
different first of all in Afghanistan
there were troops on the ground British
troops on the ground there are not
British troops on the ground in in
Khartoum and Sudan in Afghanistan the
airport was open and working the airport
in Khartoum is is out of action entirely
none of us are in any doubt as to the
complexity of the task or the difficulty
of the situation on the ground yet we
know apart the countries have evacuated
significant numbers of their Nationals
already
is desperately trying to get through to
her father Ahmed who she hasn't spoken
to since Saturday
he is a retired Jewel citizen who worked
in the NHS and went to Sudan to train
other doctors all of these countries are
bought in Planes to take people out but
they haven't tried to bring in any Aid
like for me currently my dad's on
medication he has a week left of his
medication
for now British Nationals have been told
to await instructions the government
says it's doing everything it can to
reach them Lisa Holland Sky News